dacca la sava tranquille alors voilà je
vous explique je fais une série qui
s'appelle platanes et gérard lanvin g
jean dujardin incarne oskar guillaume
canet sa femme elle a un oscar dans ça
compte et je me dis si le pape il veut
jouer dans platane c'est le top 3 quand
tu vois pourquoi garde quoi que non
l'homme alors il a dit oui alors aux ja
continue de se parler kaplan je me
disais tu ferais à super besse dans
platane
moi je sois ben non question 1 6 4 ok ok
tu as et kaplan quoi yakapark arabe
petit revenons sa branche serait de
jouer dans platane à retrouver eric
judor et son casting dans platane
nouvelle saison en septembre sur canal+